what sounds cooler than lightning yes
thunder bolt we are getting some leaks
that these new iPhones coming next year
the iPhone 15 lineup specifically those
higher end Flagship models could have
Thunderbolt which would completely
change the game and bring the iPhone
ahead of all of the other smartphones
now I know that sounds crazy but we've
been getting some leaks and rumors
including some words from Apple's
management teams themselves now a couple
of weeks back Joanna Stern interviewed
both apples Greg joswiak and Craig
federighi and she asked them about the
whole European USBC law that's going
into effect and joswax said that
obviously we will have to comply we have
no choice which really shows that we
could be getting USBC as soon as next
year as I'm going to be talking about in
this video and that's actually what Mark
German the number one apple leaker has
said and this tweet right here from
October 25th he said he won't say when
the iPhone will get it but he has
written that it is next year now a few
days ago the other co-host Max made this
video about USBC coming to the iPhone 15
lineup and the chance that Apple could
easily give us USBC but severely [ __ ] it
because that's exactly what they did to
the new iPad 10. they gave it USBC but
they gave it the same USB 2.0 speeds
which are extremely slow so there's a
chance we could get that but in this
video I'm going to be showing some leaks
and rumors that point to potentially
some of the highest end iPhone 15 models
getting Thunderbolt speeds according to
leak's Apple Pro from a tweet thread he
put out in September all four models of
the iPhone 15 lineup will get USBC and
the dynamic Island now of course the
lower end models might get slower USB
2.0 speeds and the higher end ones could
get faster he also said that the regular
iPhone 15 models will come with the a16
ship that we currently have on the 14
pro and pro Max but then that the 15 Pro
is gonna come with the a17 he then
continued to say that we could get an
iPhone 15 Ultra model yes jam-packed
being differentiated more from the
regular Pro and including the pricing
with him expecting it to start at twelve
hundred dollars at best and that would
include 8K recording which could come to
the pro and Ultra or maybe just for the
ultra and that Apple wants the battery
life to improve by three to four hours
next year especially on that Ultra model
but the craziest thing he said was that
the ultra model could come with
Thunderbolt 4 speeds which is extremely
fast up to 40gb gigabits per second
while the regular iPhone 14 pro and pro
Max models right now they operate at
just 480 megabits per second that is
very very slow and just today he came
out and said that the iPhone 15 Ultra
will cost substantially more to
manufacture than the iPhone 14 pro Max
now one of those reasons could be
because apple is still going to be
sticking to the Qualcomm modem well
everybody thought Apple would have their
own new modem which would help save
money but no it looks like Qualcomm is
going to be sticking around and of
course the other reason for the higher
cost is if they are truly putting
Thunderbolt into the iPhone 15 Ultra
which would cause them to also make the
price higher but before I get into why
that's going to be such a big deal for
the iPhone 15 Ultra model I've got to
give a shout out to the sponsor of this
video pulse way imagine all your its
systems at your fingertips where you can
essentially control all of your desktops
servers and network devices with pulse
way you can do just that whether you
need to run a script remotely connect to
a system reset a password or build an
automation workflow pulse way has you
covered and the best part they're
offering a discount if you start their
trial today so what are you waiting for
secure your discount today using the
link below and start a free no
commitment trial easy now getting back
to why Thunderbolt is going to be a huge
deal for the iPhone 15 Ultra it has to
do with the transfer speeds check out
this chart you can see that Thunderbolt
right here both four and three go up to
40 gigabits per second that is extremely
fast guess where the current iPhone is
right now even the pro and pro Max right
here USB 2.0 speeds that's 480mb bits
per second essentially making
Thunderbolt 83 times faster yes 83 times
that is absolutely
insane and believe it or not the current
Flagship Samsung Galaxy s22 Ultra
supports USB 3.2 gen 1 connectivity
which essentially means 5 gigabits per
second so if Apple brings Thunderbolt to
the iPhone 15 Ultra that is literally
gonna be eight times faster transfer
speeds on the iPhone compared to the
flagship s22 Ultra that basically means
that the iPhone is going to go from the
worst transfer speeds which is lightning
2.0 at 480 megabits per second to the
best by far and that is a huge selling
point for that Ultra model now on top of
all of that we also have some other huge
leaks that coincide with that on
September 25th shrimp Apple Pro made
this tweet iPhone with no physical
button project code name Bongo now that
might sound crazy but check out what
Ming shikwo posted on October 27th yes
he's also a very reliable source in the
Apple leak world he said that the latest
survey indicates that the volume button
and power button of two high-end iPhone
15 models May adopt a solid state button
design which means no physical
mechanical buttons If you guys remember
the home button there was a certain time
when they replaced the physical button
with a fake solid state button that
didn't actually move but when you
pressed on it the haptic motor vibrated
and made it actually seem like a real
click yes a lot of people were actually
tricked into thinking it was real but it
wasn't actually moving and that's
actually exactly how the track pads the
magic Trackpad on Apple's MacBooks works
it feels like a click but it's not it's
not a click at all and that is going to
be awesome now Manchester that there's
going to be taptic engines located on
the internal left and right sides to
provide force feedback to make users
feel like they're pressing physical
buttons and due to that change it's
going to go from one haptic motor to
three within those higher end Pro Models
and that actually signals a full
redesign which I think is coming next
year with a brand new design with glass
protruding out of the front and the back
and getting rid of those physical
buttons now having three haptic feedback
Motors is going to be really cool
because it's not only going to increase
the vibration if all of them are turned
on but Apple's going to be able to
combine them and kind of do like a
rotation to make a really unique
vibration to catch your attention for
example and the cool thing is that
you're going to be able to customize the
sensitivity and the feedback strength in
the settings and yes Ming shiko agrees
with leaks Apple Pro and Mark German
saying that the buttonless design and
switch to USBC are two of the major
updates for iPhone 15 so yes it's coming
to the iPhone 15 and not later and
another very good reason for that is the
fact that the new Siri remote on the
Apple TV switched to USBC which is the
most telling part because the Apple TV
in that remote has nothing to do with
the iPhone so why would Apple switch it
to USBC well it means that they're
planning to sell it for a while and by
next year when the iPhone switches to
USBC everything is gonna make sense and
they're gonna be moving a lot of their
other products so this fact with the
Siri remote getting USBC is very telling
for what apple is doing but the craziest
thing of all is that Mark German said
that Apple's move to USBC is just a stop
Gap until its Wireless future what does
that mean well of course it points to
the port list iPhone and you might be
wondering why would Apple make a
portless iPhone well it has to do with
why they are also getting rid of the
physical buttons and giving us the fake
solid state buttons and that actually is
a follow-up to what we're already seeing
with the the SIM card tray my theory is
that apple is working on an essentially
waterproof iPhone not only ip68 the best
waterproofing in any smartphone but
waterproof basically just like the Apple
watch and maybe even salt waterproof
because all the iPhones right now no
iPhone is salt waterproof but if Apple
can get rid of the USBC Port so make it
portless they're getting rid of the
physical buttons they're going to be
solid state and they already got rid of
the SIM card tray in the United States
that means no cracks and essentially
sealed iPhone all the way around nowhere
can water get into the buttons into the
port into the SIM card tray all of that
is now sealed and they have the best
waterproofing in the business and you
might think why would Apple want that
why would anybody want that well for
example Apple can now Market that you
can use your iPhone in the ocean water
her without having it get completely
ruined which happens to all smartphones
and even better they are no longer going
to have Apple Care claims for water
damage because all of it's going to be
nice and sealed up and they're not going
to have to pay to replace people's
iPhones with water damage which right
now AppleCare does cover it if you pay
the 100 deductible and going even
further it's going to discourage people
from opening up their iPhone and fixing
it themselves because you're going to
mess with those crazy water seals so
they could be making money that way as
well so that is where the iPhone is
headed towards a fully portless design
and future but for now next year we are
expecting USBC on the iPhone 15s and
hopefully Thunderbolt on the higher end
models maybe just the iPhone 15 Ultra so
if you disagree with anything in this
video let me know in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]